is joining us now education secretary
Jillian Keegan also used to be Health
minister of course thoughts on the
nurses going on strike of course nobody
wants the nurses to go on strike and we
would urge the nurses not to go on
strike we are recovering from the
pandemic and we really really need our
nurses right now everybody really needs
our health care System you know we know
we've got millions of people waiting for
catch-up operations and scans and and
treatments so we very much hope that you
know discussions will continue but we
very much hope that they don't go on
strike but of course it's not just the
nurses we've seen many many other people
balloting for strike as well including
teachers and postal workers and many
others are a balloting for strike action
and you know we understand why because
of course inflation is infecting
everybody it's impacting every business
every organization every household
that's what we're seeing everybody's
seeing it everybody's uncertain about
their Futures what's going to happen to
mortgage rates Etc so we do understand
we do understand why it's difficult but
there's a key message I think Kay which
is you cannot spend your way out of
inflation you really can't and the
number one thing we have to do is tattle
inflation otherwise whatever we do it
will all be eaten out by inflation so
that's the number one thing that we have
to do and have to achieve did you clap
for gnosis during the pandemic of course
everyone did yes so are you comfortable
comfortable that they're now using food
banks in order to be able to survive
well I mean I go to my food banks quite
a lot and and ask you know why is it
what what is it what's the reason why
people are there at food banks and quite
often when you when you go to food banks
it will be people something will have
happened you know something will have
broken down either a relationship or a
boiler or anything they're usually
they're in an emergency situation
um I know there was a lot of focus on
increasing the starting salary for
nurses there was a lot of focus on
making sure that lower paid people in
the nursing profession
um were were also increased but you know
there's no doubt that people are worried
very worried about inflation
do you think nurses get paid enough
well I think the average when I last
looked was 34 000.
before these increases so it's you know
it's more than the you know the average
salary of of across the country but you
know in some ways you can you can never
say nurses get paid enough they're so
valuable I mean I've just my nephews
just had an 11 hour surgery uh last you
know night before last you know there is
no way anybody who's in that situation
can underestimate just how important
nurses and doctors are I mean they are
literally a Lifeline to many people we
should be paying them more well we pay
them obviously there's the independent
review bodies there's
1.3 million people work in the NHS so
you know and it's obviously public
sector so you've got to get the balance
between you know how much you pay it's a
huge bill it's a huge uh cost at the NHS
um and you've got to get the balance
right because of course its taxpayers
who have to pay that bill but if we
don't pay them anymore they're going to
go on strike many others are leaving
apparently if you want to work for
Amazon and Aldi
well you know they're very different
jobs working for Aldi and Amazon and um
and working as a nurse you know they are
very different jobs very different hours
very different rewards in terms of
personal rewards as well I mean this is
often I mean I've been in the skills and
apprenticeship Minister you know we've
got 1.3 million vacancies and often
people say social care was a was a big
part of it because social care workers
are paid less than nurses uh
considerably less than nurses and this
was always the question about how to
make sure they had more rewarding career
options but also
um you know could could also
um you know increase their their salary
or go off to little or whatever
um and the reality is you know people
who work in Social care work in Social
care because they know people rely on
them they love looking after the people
they they're a Lifeline too but you know
getting that and that's a private sector
but getting that balance right is always
what we seek to do making sure we've got
new nurses coming in I went and opened a
new uh School of Nursing and Allied
Health in Chichester three Fridays ago
it's really important that we offer
apprenticeships I've talked about
apprenticeships a lot at all various
levels and that's also for people who
want to retrain uh later on together
they go on strike there's no more money
so there's no point in them going on
strike well I don't think there's any
point in going on strike anyway I think
it's um you know when we're in a
position where we've got millions and
millions of people waiting for
operations or
um for help waiting for for medical help
and the only people who can give that
medical help are largely our nurses and
our doctors so I think it you know it's
irresponsible I wouldn't say that
because I understand that I understand
the difficult
um I think I understand the difficulty
right it is really worrying for people
not just in our country across the world
we are all facing the headwinds
obviously we know why the the two years
you can't close down the global economy
for two years and not expect anything to
happen that's what's happened and we now
have to recover from that and then on
top of that of course we've got the war
in Ukraine in which is playing Havoc
with energy Supply and energy pricing we
know why we know we're all in it uh and
and you know I would I would urge the
nurses to
um you know to continue those
discussions but the reality is
it's if we gave massive above inflation
Rises Not only would we have to raise a
lot more money but it would actually
fuel inflation this is the problem we
really have to tattle inflation we have
to make sure that that is there is is
really brought under control although
anything we do they won't notice when
you were working in the health Ministry
you were responsible for mental health
yes awareness weren't you
um what do you make of somebody like
Gavin Williamson using someone's mental
health against them well I mean it's
inappropriate to use anybody's mental
health against them I mean obviously
he's denied the allegations and he said
he's uh doesn't want to be a distraction
and he's uh going to uh um repute them
from the back benches via the via the
independent process but mental health is
very serious a lot of people who are
um suffering from from mental health and
are concerned about their mental health
a lot of young people as well obviously
now I'm responsible for Education a lot
of young people who are concerned about
their mental health and you know people
when they're suffering from mental
health need support they need the right
support from the right professionals or
from people around them sometimes as
well if it's lower left and they don't
need the chief whip using it against
them the then Chief whip his deputy said
that he was using people's mental health
against them yeah well these are
allegations which he's obviously denying
and he's obviously gone back uh
well I you know I've worked with him
several times and I haven't seen any of
that he's never threatened me or he's
only only ever been supportive actually
personally to me
um but I wouldn't say I've known very
well I mean I I was reading today about
this Curry Club I've never been invited
to that you know I've never been out on
a night out or anything like that but in
terms of working and professional
um he's he's in a way in messages that
he's been speaking to the previous Chief
whip a woman I mean yeah totally yeah
appropriate unacceptable and I think he
apologized for that that was
unacceptable I mean you know I I've
barely have meetings with the chief whip
which is probably a good thing but um
you know I know that there are some
quite robust conversations I've seen all
the plays about uh Chief whips and that
kind of thing but it is unacceptable
it's unacceptable and I think it was
right that he apologized was it right
that he resigned yes I think it is you
know he said it was a distraction and it
is a distraction because we've got
really sort of serious things that we
need to navigate navigating this
Economic Times is going to be quite
tricky and obviously Jeremy Hunt the
chancellor is is working on that at the
moment but that and you'll hear about
that a week uh tomorrow but we've also
got the war in Ukraine the last time I
was on this program with UK
um Putin was threatening escalation of
the war in Ukraine you know we still
don't you know we're still keeping very
close to that to to know how uh that's
going to develop it's a really serious
thing of course they are of course they
are but it doesn't excuse his behavior
what it does do is bring into question
which is your next judgment well I think
the whole country saw uh Rishi sunak's
judgment on display all over the summer
when he very clearly give him a job when
he was being investigated for bullying
well he very he very clearly over the
summer Rishi told everybody what they
didn't want to hear but what was the
right thing which was basically what we
need to do to navigate these difficult
times and he was given those hard
messages people didn't want to hear them
but that I think showed his judgment
that's why I backed him I thought you're
absolutely right on this and even though
it's hard messages there's no avoiding
these hard messages was it right to give
Gavin Williamson a job when he was being
investigated well of course he wanted to
bring in all the different talents he
wanted to bring a mix of experience new
faces
um I think at that point
um I don't I think there'd been some
conversation which you know there'd been
a disagreement between uh two Chief
whips or the former Chief Two former
Chief whips I guess at that point
um so you know there was a conversation
about a disagreement that was all you
know it wasn't an investigation there
wasn't an official investigation well I
think he resigned very quickly you know
this all started from what I understand
it started over the weekend you know and
and he resigned on Tuesday before he was
owned well I think Gavin did the right
thing by resigning you know I think it's
uh it's it's had the same impact you
know he's not he's now going to be on
the back benches and he's going to be
fighting the allegations as he says we
which he disputes well he doesn't
dispute what he said to the information
no he's apologized for those words yeah
you're the fifth education secretary in
four months doesn't the department
deserve better
well I think I'm pretty good if I'm
honest about reflecting on you
particularly but I'm reflecting on the
fact that you've had um uh five
education secretaries in four months
yeah we better continuity we have
definitely gone through a difficult time
as as a conservative party there is no
doubt about that where the great
resignations lots of people's resigned
and then obviously that led to uh to
Boris and then we had a leadership
contest that led to Liz and now of
course we know what happened there with
the uh the fiscal event or the mini
budget as it's called and the Market's
reaction and now we've got what what I
campaigned for over the summer actually
which was for Rishi sunak to be the
Prime Minister and of course that comes
with some changes
um but one of the things about education
I walked back in because I have been an
educator in fact it was my first
ministerial role apprenticeships and
skills I walked back in pretty much I
would say three-quarters of the people I
knew already they were the same people
who were there we brought back Nick Gibb
who has been very consistently driving
up school standards since 2010 Rob
halffin who's very experienced in the
department and then one one of the
brightest new MPS from the 2019 intake
Claire coutino so it's got It's a really
good mix of experience and and and
people who I think will be able to
really hit the ground running then we've
got Diana Baron in the Lord her teacher
tell me all the her teachers are telling
us that um they need more money uh
because otherwise they're gonna have to
sack members of Staff yeah so there's a
website gone up with a model behind it
which has made some assumptions
obviously as models always do again
there's no doubt that we're going
through difficult times I could tell I
could look at any household any
organization any business two things are
happening Energy prices have gone up of
course that's why we've got the energy
relief bill uh scheming so there will be
more money for schools well we have put
four billion extra will there be schools
schools are one of the well obviously
there is a fiscal uh you know there's a
Autumn budget which is a week tomorrow
so you're gonna have to wait it's gonna
be Cuts aren't there to the education
budget no you get the the the set the
the four billion pounds was actually
probably it was the second biggest
increase but we're going to see 15 cuts
across the board aren't we
um I think it depends on what happens
with inflation how they calculate what
contracts they've got I mean the ifs has
looked at it and said look we think that
school budgets can manage this year but
the uncertainty goes out when it goes
out further than that and if any school
is in distress or any school really is
in trouble there is a scheme whereby you
can come to the department we work with
schools to make sure that they've get
all the efficiencies they can but also
get the support they can but can I just
say okay it's a first time on his
education sector I have no doubt that
this is really really a difficult time
for head teachers and for teachers and
our teachers have done the most amazing
job during the pandemic I remember going
around to schools they were grappling
with the technology having to do things
online having to do things at home
looking after their own kids as well
they were absolutely fantastic they know
they're a Lifeline to our kids they know
every single day they're catching up
every single day they're providing that
inspiration to kids we want them to
continue to do that we really need them
we all need them parents need them kids
need them we all need them together
we're almost out of time two very quick
questions so you're gonna watch the
crown
yes I've watched the previous ones yeah
um it's King Charles will not like it
trust me I've seen the first three
episodes and are you going to vote for
Matt Hancock I don't watch that program
and therefore I probably won't no okay
do you think you did the right thing I
can't imagine why you would want to do
it I really cannot imagine I can't think
of anything worse than eating bugs or
having bugs crawl over you in public in
public I can't think of anything worse I
mean you know I guess he's Brave yeah or
stupid one of them or maybe a bit of
both
um how is your nephew is he all right he
is he's still in the Royal London thank
you so much to the Royal London because
uh yeah 11 hours is a long time to be in
surgery but thank you for asking um but
yeah he's it's a serious operation but
hopefully he's okay now fantastic it's
great to see you education secretary
thank you very much new for joining us